And again, that same old question:
Why wouldn't we do this?
What you see in the picture
is the beginning of 426 primary school children
who were walked up the hill by the head teacher,
who didn't want them to lose this opportunity.
And just as happens in the Nevada desert,
though in slightly different temperatures,
the people of this community, 65,000 of them,
turned out to write their grief, their pain, their hope,
their hopes for the future,
their love.
Because in the end, this is only about love.
They live in a post-conflict society:
lots of post-traumatic stress,
high suicide.
And yet, for this brief moment --
and it would be ridiculous to assume that it was more than that --
somebody like Kevin -- a Catholic whose father was shot when he was nine,
upstairs in bed --
Kevin came to work as a volunteer.
And he was the first person to embrace the elderly Protestant lady
who came through the door on the day we opened the temple to the public.
It rose up. It sat there for five days.
And then we chose -- from our little tiny band of nonsectarian builders,
who had given us their lives for this period of months
to make this extraordinary thing --
we chose from them the people who would incinerate it.
And here you see the moment when,
witnessed by 15,000 people who turned out on a dark, cold, March evening,
the moment when they decided to put their enmity behind them,
to inhabit this shared space,
where everybody had an opportunity to say the things that had been unsayable,
to say out loud,
"You hurt me and my family, but I forgive you."
And together, they watched
as members of their community let go of this thing that was so beautiful,
but was as hard to let go of
as those thoughts and feelings
that had gone into making it.
(Music)
Thank you.
(Applause)